foreign
[Music]
Ed in their ways their technology
their weapons
things that a not be should not know
and then one day
they left Hell's Gate is under attack
evacuate now to all the navi children
but before they did our teacher saved us
and put us to sleep this is your only
chance to survive
and there I remain for 15 years
until one day
I awoke
and I was free
free to explore my world
free to decide who I was going to be
cover what I was meant to do
[Music]
now you see what you would tip to front
thank you
now Pandora is under attack again
don't let the Navi get in our way get
rid of them and I have a choice to make
I choose to protect my home
foreign
[Music]